[Musique]
cela fait 35 ans que micheline lapierre
vendée propriété depuis le début de la
pandémie
les prix n'ont cessé d'augmenter et les
rares condos et maisons sur le marché
s'envole à la vitesse de l'éclair
[Musique]
combien sont ils vendus plus cher que le
prix demandé au général à la bienvenue
c'est toujours d'abord open destin c'est
avec la purée hockey ainsi les visites
de condos comme celui ci sont sur rendez
vous seulement et se succèdent aux 15
minutes
ce condo de quelques années seulement
situé à longueuil est affiché à 390
mille dollars
le logement attire beaucoup d'acheteurs
potentiels qui ne se font pas trop
d'illusions sur l'issue de la course au
condo lucie couillard a déjà fait
plusieurs offres sur d'autres propriétés
sans succès - ce prix là qu'elle était
un disque est présentement elle me
convient mais si on est 4 5 p une seule
manche en baie de valence en mille de
plus monsieur est rendue mais moi je
vous dis je trouve ça bien parce que
j'ai vendu ma maison et j'ai 55 jours à
trouver une maison comme you moins
d'opportunités mais ils ont tendance à
vouloir mettre plus sur chacune des
opportunités ce qui crée un effet le
comme on observe à l'heure actuelle
saisir des surenchères et les pandémies
n'a rien arrangé dans un marché qui
souffrait déjà d'un manque de logement
depuis quelques années au niveau de la
demande dont faisait le fait qu'ils
aient moins de migration internationale
ça va peut-être lâché de marché mais en
même temps le fait que les gens aient
cessé leur activité ou reporter des
projets se faire en sorte que les gens
bougent moins dans l'espace
en tout cas pas de répit ce dimanche
pour micheline lapierre qui s'en va à
une autre porte ouverte à montréal c'est
toute une organisation de planifier des
fois on peut avoir des offres d'achat en
général on peut avoir des fois ça dépend
des propriétés on peut avoir de 20 à 50
visites dans un week-end dans le
quartier montréalais ville émard cette
petite maison qui est à vendre
mise à prix un demi million de dollars
et en a pas énormément donc l'effet
qu'il ya une cour qui a une maison pic
la maison un peu à des mollets c'est
quand même elle est quand même vivable
la maison donc oui c'est encore c'est
très recherché
d'ailleurs le va et vient des amateurs
ne se dément pas même si selon certains
d'entre eux on est loin de la maison de
rêve et qu'il y a beaucoup de travail à
réaliser avant de pouvoir l'habiter il
reste que la pression est là pour les
acheteurs cas pas de chance dans le
marché actuellement
quand je dis que t'as pas de chance et
ce fut 9 d'achat depuis quand c'est au
moment de la présentation en fait on
fait plus de contre offres ont choisi la
meilleure offre d'achat avec les
meilleures conditions possibles c'est
quoi finalement un vingt mille de plus
amorti son hypothèque pendant 25 ans le
5 e tour en ce moment peut la voir la
concurrence en tout cas est féroce pour
hugo bertrand on a fait des offres
seraient fermés secteur on n'a jamais
été la bonne offre choisi même avec une
pandémie qui devrait s'éloigner petit à
petit en attendant les effets de ce
resserrement du marché immobilier ne
disparaîtront pas du jour au lendemain
les gens vont se tasser dans les
logements existants
il va avoir des subdivisions était en
débat world la sous location de la
colocation les enfants les jeunes vont
rester plus longtemps chez leurs parents
pour que le marché soit plus abordable
et doté de plus de logement la balle est
dans le camp des municipalités selon
jean-philippe molosses comment est-ce
qu'on peut changer par exemple les
réglementations dans les municipalités
pour favoriser la densification de
certains quartiers autorisé des
logements intergénérationnels ce soit
interdit dans les mines spect
de retour au condo de longueuil
pablo sandoval et marie à brno espère
pouvoir l'acheter comme premier logement
on a fait quelques visites déjà et on
est rendu compte que ça passe très vite
la marche est sacrée on a fait quelques
visites le plus tôt possible pour
décider à acheter si c'est possible le
pack sinon on n'a pas lâché asap andré
nous on a conduit sur deux étages
micheline lapierre a en tout cas un
conseil pour les jeunes acheteurs qui
songe à ne pas faire d'inspection du
logement pour être sûr d'être choisi par
les vendeurs y en a qui vont une fois
ils vont vouloir la faire pareil parce
qu'ils veulent tellement pas perdre la
maison il y en a sont prêtes à faire
toutes sortes de choses
enlevez le plus de conditions possibles
mais c'est passé pour conseil et arceaux
et la beau prêcher pour sa paroisse il
reste que selon elle le découragement
est à proscrire
c'est toujours bon pour un acheté parce
que ça a toujours un ou dix en général
les maisons nobles mais que des fois
c'est savary un petit peu c'est certain
mais on n'est jamais perdu
la preuve est cette petite maison
montréalaise et ce condo de longueuil
ont trouvé preneur avec plusieurs offres
toutes plus élevé que le prix demandé
des prix qui resteront secrets